francis hogan told mps this week that
your company is unquestionably making
hate worse
is this true what's your response
yeah good morning vanessa and thanks for
having me uh the answer is categorically
that's not true uh in fact if you look
at the investments that we've made over
the last few years on safety and
integrity uh we've actually invested
more than 13 billion dollars 5 billion
in this year alone and we have 40 000
people focus wholly on safety and
integrity at face who would strongly
disagree with that claim but perhaps let
me put some numbers behind that as well
what that means is in some of the most
challenging areas like hate speech
because we're dealing with the nuances
of language we've seen the prevalence of
hate speech on facebook uh declined by
three quarters over the last two years
so it's a fraction of a fraction of a
percent still more than we want but
we're definitely seeing progress there
and you know certainly as we think about
what the next iteration of technology
looks like taking those technologies
that put safety and integrity in the
heart are really important as we build
out the metaverse
and she touched on safety for children
she said i'm deeply worried that it may
not be possible to make instagram safe
for a 14 year old and i sincerely doubt
that it is possible to make it safe for
a 10 year old can you assure parents
that your social media services are safe
for children
yes i mean i mean just for the record
here you know our services are for
people that are 13 and above and you
know we take tremendous care in making
sure that teenagers were all users but
teenagers in particular and we have
special features to protect teens so you
know just for example we just recently
announced a new feature where if you are
over 18 you cannot now direct message
somebody on instagram who's under 18.
that if they're not following you so
that means mum and dad or grammar or
whoever if you'll follow if that
teenager has chosen to that they'll be
able to follow you can message but
strangers can't and that's just one
example of all the work that we're doing
every single day you know a lot of the
research that that's out there actually
says that on on other for teenagers
instagram is positive to neutral in
terms of in terms of its impact but even
if there's a single degree of kind of
negative we want to work really hard and
that's why we do that research to uh to
make sure that we're making any changes
that we can and when we look to the
future of of technology and where it's
going and these these questions are
really important it's why we're building
the metaverse really slowly so we
announced our contribution there last
night i mean just to be clear i mean the
metaverse is going to happen whether
facebook is involved or not just like
the internet it's going to take many
companies many organizations many
entrepreneurs and individuals
and and
at the heart of this if we think about
uh where we've been over the last couple
of years the pandemic has underscored
even if we needed it just the importance
of being in close contact with people in
real life
but when that isn't possible what
technology has enabled us to do is have
some form of online presence and that's
moved from how the technology has moved
from being about accessing the internet
through through typing through words
which is you know can be a bit clumsy in
a dyslexic like me a bit awkward to
movies to videos to this next step where
it's a much more immersive experience
where we have that sense of what's
called presence and that's kind of a
hard thing to describe but i think we
know it when we feel it uh when you're
that close and that's what these new
technologies are going to do and they're
going to create an already creating
really interesting new way so whether
that's school children putting a bit of
their class time aside not just to read
about the uh the streets of ancient rome
but be there uh whether that's surgeons
coming together as they do now in
virtual reality to practice their
expertise or if you're a bit like me
you're excited about the abba global
tour that's going to come from the
olympic park in london next year so all
of these things are in a way giving us
glimpses of what this technology is
going to enable
well talking about the pandemic will you
apologize for allowing vaccine and
coronavirus misinformation on your
platform
well we've worked
on an almost daily basis since it'd be
very much the beginning of the pandemic
with the wh show
and in this country and health services
and authorities around the world the nhs
in this country in particular and what
that's meant is we've removed tens of
millions of pieces of harmful content
we've dramatically reduced hundreds of
millions of pieces of content and
importantly we've made sure that we're
directing people to the right incredible
accurate information in fact over two
billion people have been directed to
accurate information the who and and
and other services like the nhs by us so
it was a really big responsibility to
make sure that we've been getting this
right and all the work we've been doing
is being led by the experts um that's
work it's continuing you know i think we
know that we are we are we are not
finished here yet we're going to make
sure that we're doing everything that we
possibly can
and that name change meta what's the
point of it what are you hoping to
achieve by that
well the name changing of itself um is
to to do two things uh one which is to
set out this longer term vision for the
metaverse as as i outlined and and and
the second part of that is just to bring
more clarity to our organization you
know right now it's probably an
important thing to say to all of the
viewers that the the apps that facebook
the company now met at the company so
facebook instagram whatsapp and others
that people use every day they're not
changing at all it is about our company
and setting out that 5 10 15 year vision
for these new technologies that we think
will put connection and contact and
what's called presence right at the
heart of the evolution of technology you
know it's incredible this might some of
this stuff might sound like science
fiction right now but it's quite
incredible just how quickly technology
can evolve and how quickly we get used
to things so even something like video
calling which you know when i was a
younger you know that would really be
the subject of science fiction and now
it's something that you know so many
people do on every single day and that's
you know actually a good indicator of
just how much we can see this progress
happening and how we're going to be
excited about building this next level
of what the internet is going to look
like from based in our
desktops which you know i'm using that
right now to to do the zoom call then it
moved on to our phones now it's going to
move into a way where instead of looking
at the internet we get a chance to be
involved in it and participate in a way
that
could be video calling with my mum next
to me through augmented glasses or you
know it could be as i said before
brilliant educational benefits with
brilliant payment benefits